Howdy, y'all.
Wait, let me fix some of my setup.
Hello!
Howdy.
Howdy, howdy doody.
I'm at a convention this weekend.
In Texas, y'all.
But not one single person has said that they know Sandy Cheeks.
Weird.
OMG, it's a minto!
It's mint!
It's mint.
Where's the swimsuit?
Okay, for those who don't know...
We were just watching Ayami-sensei's panel.
Where she drew...
She...
She... drew...
She... drew... V?
I think...
Maybe Isekai version?
I have a screenshot that I was gonna post on Twitter.
That...
That has a funny face that she made too.
Just...
...
Do you see the resemblance?
I finally got a flight out of Long Beach!
No way!
You finally got one!
Oh my gosh, Big Mac.
Oh my gosh.
Please go home.
Who is this?
I'm really in love with the Asuna face she gave me though.
Where did those come from?
I don't know!
Here they are.
My two big bulging...
My eyes are here.
I stand by what I said, even when it wasn't me who said it.
Play MGS5 first everyone for the true experience.
No!
I had a panel even.
I talked about Metal Gear.
I'm saying this is a happy anniversary.
Thank you Luna!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
You gave me the Wisp plushie, right?
I...
Beat it up every day.
Take out my aggressions, you know?
Homer, I've made my choice.
ViviCore, thank you for the 5 gifted!
And Mdrangles, thank you for the 20 gifted!
And Oddballboy, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
She hates us.
Wisp plushie...
Was I supposed to say that?
Maybe I shouldn't have said that.
Wow, this is...
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
So glad your MGS panel was streamed.
It was really fun.
Really?
It wasn't...
It was...
I'm glad...
I gave you the Wisp plushie.
Glad you're beating it up.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
I did it!
Happy belated anniversary.
Thank you!
Too much!
That's too much.
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Minto-chan, good morning!
Good morning!
I'm cursed by EU time zones but happy birthday.
No!
I'm streaming a little early today.
SSR Minto, summer real.
Yeah.
Wait, what's the other S though?
Super summer real.
Super summer real Minto.
Maybe she'll post the finished version.
On Twitter.
Mr. Obvious, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
I have a friend who was at the panel.
He had an absolute blast, he said thanks.
Oh man...
I didn't...
I don't make panels so I didn't really know what to do at all.
I had no idea what to say...
I was like, I can't make this like a...
How...
Know everything about Metal Gear...
like that I just was like...
Well, I'll just talk about Metal Gear and then start to do solo panels.
Yeah, I didn't want to be like, okay, the history of Metal Gear Solid.
I wanted it to be like a little bit more...
A little more silly, I think.
You did well alone?
Okay, I'm glad.
Love the fighting second?
Thank you!
I saw it on Twitch, ignoring an important work meeting.
Yeah, it's so much fun.
If you watched it, thank you so much.
If not, I believe it might still be on the Anime Fest Dallas Twitch channel.
Metal Gear Scholar.
But today...
How do I get to it, actually?
Wait, I think it's under here.
Edit map?
No, no.
How do I go to the maps?
Isn't there play?
Community?
I found it!
Today, I would like to play some custom maps.
And, you know...
I kind of... Sorry, I'm super brain empty, you guys.
I'm so...
I'm not burned out.
I think I'm just overworked a little bit.
And I feel like... I feel bad because I'm like, oh gosh...
I'm gonna be brain empty and just playing Bloons every day.
But... Sorry... Sorry for monkey brain.
You guys, I have something to tell you.
I have something to tell you.
In August... Okay, so I go to Otakuton.
And then, like...
Just a couple days later...
I fly to Japan.
And I'm gonna be in Japan...
For over a month.
It's somehow...
Turned into that.
So basically, I made plans with Mataro.
And then something else came up.
And I thought it was a good opportunity.
So I didn't say no.
But... I'll have all my stuff.
I'll still be streaming.
I will...
Attempting schedules and everything.
So...
I'll still be streaming.
I'm so sorry that my schedules have been...
So...
Not great recently.
But...
After September...
After I get back...
Things will be more normal.
I've said no to things.
But I've also said yes to things.
Congratulations on your honeymoon in Japan.
With who?
Ayami.
Ayami?
It's great to meet you yesterday.
I hope my sister's keychain plush made it to you without it.
Thank you!
I can't wait to get it.
They said they were gonna send it to me.
So...
Yeah!
I will get it!
I hope someday travels to Japan for the 50th time this year.
IT'S NOT MY FAULT!
It's not my fault.
Because, uh...
Um...
It's really just like...
Like I said, the one thing...
That I got asked to do...
And then...
Matara and I weren't even gonna...
I wasn't even gonna do the second trip to Japan.
It's because Matara gave me COVID!
And so we couldn't do anything...
That we wanted to!
BEFORE!
Stop beating yourself up.
It's still fun to bully someone who bullies himself.
You still bully me!
P.S.
Short and stanky.
You still bully me!
I'm from Texas but I'm sorry I couldn't go to work, boss.
What?
That's totally fine!
Fixie!
Oh my gosh.
But um...
So...
It's gonna be a busy month for me.
It already was.
This month.
But I'm having fun!
Let's see what the newest maps are.
Sometimes you get some really funny maps in here.
Sometimes you get some really cra- Oh!
Wait, I can show you my favorites!
Here's my favorite maps.
We have the monkey ice god.
We have the Edelwood ticket.
Isn't that Edelwood?
Isn't that from...
Over the Garden Wall?
We have Five Nights at Freddy's.
We have...
Why are you in my swamp?
We have Maxwell the cat.
We have this really awesome Interstellar one.
My head's kinda big.
Interstellar.
And then Aqua.
Aqua.
Aqua from Konosuba.
Yeah.
COVID?
Nah, you got cute vids.
Maxwell or Riot?
It's so awesome, right?
Just make sure you get your rest.
Brain frog is real.
I know.
I am worried about the brain frog.
But I've also been planning some stuff as well.
I've been trying to be like...
Okay.
If I have free day, I do this.
So, yeah.
Gonna leave her behind in economy class again.
She wasn't even in economy class.
But also, we're not flying together this time.
I wonder if there's any mint ones.
Mint.
Aww.
Mint monkey.
What about Minto?
I have a question as a new Wisp.
I've been trying to figure out...
Figure this out for a good while.
What is that big ol' spike on the top of your head?
Is it part of the maid outfit?
Or is it a hat?
What is it?
Let me see if I can pull up a picture.
It's actually...
It's actually a ghost thing.
Hitaikakushi.
It's called a Hitaikakushi.
And it's something you'll often see ghosts wearing.
Here, here.
Here, here, here.
Like this.
Here, here.
That's such a great question.
Also, thanks for being here.
New Wisp.
Everybody be nice to the new Wisp.
See, see?
But mine is just kind of off-centered a little bit.
It's her horn because she's horny.
That's not wrong.
But it's also not the case here.
I thought it was a dunce cap.
A...
A dunce cap?
I'll tell you.
I have an IQ of 181.
I have an IQ...
of 187.
I just gained 5...
6 IQ points just now.
I...
I... My IQ...
My IQ is older than your dog.
Your grandma.
And their ages combined.
My IQ is higher than your family bloodline.
Dunce cap.
But yeah, it's called a Hitaikakushi.
Or a ghost triangle.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh though!
These look so good!
I do remember seeing them on Twitter.
But thank you for uploading them.
Ghost triangle.
Ghost horn.
Gold.
You know what?
Let's do the Minto maps.
I have another meet and greet later on.
So uh...
What time is that?
Let me confirm.
Uh...
Um...
Let me see.
Where's the... Where's my schedule?
Wait.
There's my schedule.
I have another one and...
I have a lot of hours.
8.30 CST.
Am I gonna see you there again, rice nut?
No!
Hahaha!
I was so shocked.
The meet and greets were like in front of everybody.
Let him live?
Hahaha!
No!
Difficulty...
What's medium?
Oh yeah, we'll do medium.
We were shocked too!
I know!
You didn't know either?
No!
I had no idea.
It was my first time that it was like a...
public meet and greet like that.
It was so crazy.
But everyone was so funny.
Even the person that showed me like fetish art of mine.
Hahaha!
That they commissioned.
They were like, do you wanna see...
some art I commissioned of you?
And I was like, yeah!
And they showed me a picture and I was like...
Oh!
So cute!
And I was like, why am I holding a frying pan?
And then he was like...
Do you wanna see another picture that's like...
A little more...
Risky?
And I was like...
Yeah!
And then he showed it to me.
I was like...
Why do I have a frying pan now?
It was a chubby Minto!
I was like, huh?
Oh my god.
Was it because you were cooking?
More ways than one.
Probably.
I was like, oh my god, no.
This is...
Sometimes...
I think we're too comfortable...
with each other.
Hahaha!
Where can I put...
I can't in my hair.
But sometimes in my hair.
Oh wait, this is the pathway, right?
Wow, there's so much space!
Oh, I can't in the flowers.
Or on my...
leaves.
I can put here.
Okay, let's just do...
Here, I'm gonna put...
Soda.
Okay, this might be stupid.
I'm gonna put soda at the end.
So we can see what the pathway is.
We can always move her.
Here they go!
Around my face!
They're framing me!
Should this be...
No, I feel like with the ice monkey only challenge...
We could have...
a sword.
We'll do the ice monkey god...
God...
I'm gonna shrink myself a little bit.
We'll do the ice monkey god...
map.
And we'll do only...
ice monkeys.
Wait, what can be my nose?
Why didn't you give me a nose?
It's missing.
Become your own nose.
This...
This can be my nose.
There's a spot...
for 00 ice monkey in the center of the heart.
Also, all the blue is water.
We can put ice monkey in the center of the heart?
No way.
What a great map, Ashen!
Thank you!
Uh-oh.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
No!
They're getting through!
Handle it!
Miss Mel-chan!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
Be fast.
Be swift.
But yeah, the con has been a lot of fun so far.
I had a first panel.
That one was also streamed with...
with two other...
two other VTubers.
And...
Oh my god.
With Mika and Zane.
And they put together a powerpoint.
Or like a guess the monster thing for me.
Oh wait, so these are water.
Oh nice.
Is this water too?
Oh!
Wow, it's all water!
I wanna make my own map.
But you have to pay for it.
Minto, your Godot senses.
What can I say?
When I say that I love someone or something...
It's true love.
Is this a... Oh, here.
I'm trying to... How can I...
Maybe I should make the plane my...
my nose.
The Hannin sound was crazy.
It was just because it was a shadow person.
But it ended up being even crazier than I expected.
I didn't think I was right.
Like how you love snake.
Yeah.
Hehehe.
Sexy soup.
For those...
Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
Sana, what are you doing?
We're gonna...
Oh, good, good, good.
Here we go.
My nose.
I look like a piggy.
Come on, thanks!
I love Chibi Minto so much.
I think it's the Garfield-like, uninterested expression in your eyes.
Thank you, thank you.
I
hate Mondays.
I hate Mondays.
You should have said your Hitaikakushi was like a...
was a horn.
Like venom snake's horn grows more the... grows the more you make wisps cry.
Oinky doink.
My brain is so empty today.
I think also...
I had to take some...
like medicine.
And I still am hungover from the...
It's like an allergy medicine.
You know when you take an allergy medicine and it makes your brain fog so much.
The Texan air.
My nose is sideways.
Nose!
It's fine this way.
Sticks with me the whole next day.
Yeah, I know!
Me too!
It's so like...
The antihistamines.
Ate Mondays.
Love lasagna.
Simple airs.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
It was prescribed antihistamines for sleeping tablets.
One time...
Yeah, I've been given...
They gave one time...
One time they gave me medicine.
That was like a daily medicine.
That was antihistamine.
I was like, I can't take this.
It was... I'll just say it.
It was an anti-anxiety...
It was anti-anxiety meds.
And I was like...
I'm gonna be more anxious cause I'm tired!
Because I can't wake up!
Loki, thanks for the tech gifted!
But yeah, ever since I took the medicine...
The Benadryl, I've been like...
My brain...
I can't wake up.
Take your ghost meds.
Alright, let's see.
Let's do...
Which ones?
Flying fortress.
I love never miss targeting!
Never miss!
Oh...
Whoa!
Guys, I think we're in trouble.
Come on!
Keep popping!
Guys, we're already...
We've lost so many lives.
I have to take my anxiety meds before bed.
You're smart.
But even still, like...
The next day just makes me be like...
That's why I'm monkey brain right now.
Bust those balloons!
Come on!
Monkey brain!
Minto map doesn't play around.
You know what, let's...
Wait, where does it start?
Shoot.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, start squishing.
Start squishing those...
Bigger globs.
New generation Anihistamines are safer.
Benadryl hits really hard and ain't supposed to be great on the daily.
Oh, I don't take it daily.
I took it...
I took it two days ago.
And I'm still feeling it.
I'm like, whoa.
Uh oh.
We're losing more stuff, you guys.
I think we're in trouble.
I think we might be in trouble.
This map is pretty hard with its short path.
Why'd you gotta make it so difficult?
How'd you draw everything?
It's literally...
It's literally me.
It's me if I had a tan.
Minto goes to the beach.
Fake.
Oh my god.
Go Sara!
Go!
Oh, she's faster now!
She's faster now.
She's leveled up.
Yes!
So is Ice Monkey.
He's faster now.
Come on.
Nice.
Tan lines on Mint Artist, please.
Summer's got you thinking summer-brained.
Is that Mumei?
Thank you for the tan gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I don't ever...
I, you know... Oh, shoot.
Uh oh.
Oh, wait.
We have Sawada.
She's great.
Um...
I...
Even when I would go out a lot...
and outside...
I never got tan lines or anything.
I'm a...
I'm a ghost that burns.
My ectoplasm burns.
I do not tan.
So it's...
So it's hard for me to...
Because you're a ghost.
Yeah.
I don't tan though.
But it's kind of sad, right?
Like...
Okay.
Okay, we're so close.
Come on.
Come on, Sawada.
Don't let him pass.
Handle it.
She reflects all the beams.
Come on!
Once we have the never-miss, we'll be so good.
Yeah!
Not even a farmer's tan?
You know how like some people, if they drive, they get like a driver's tan?
Like just the...
Just the left side of their...
Or I guess depends on where you drive.
If you drive on the left side or the right side.
My favorite game.
Balloon...Balloon Teddy 6.
Is that related to Ben 10?
Uh oh.
Wait.
I need something!
I need Scissor 61!
Uh oh.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
You!
No!
I can't be...
Oh,
you sawed his ability!
What does this do?
Oh, neat!
I have to pay for them.
Which one would you want, Ashen?
You want right...
Can I give...
35% of any accolade purchase goes directly to the registered player.
You can make money off of this?
Time to quit my job.
Why?
Okay.
Ashen Offstream, I'm gonna give you...
I'm gonna give you...
Dancing Monkey.
I'm gonna give you RGB Monkey.
I'm gonna give it to you.
Rip Bozo.
Shut up!
Shut up to you!
I can't believe I lost.
I mean, I can.
I wasn't playing very well.
Let's try the next one.
This one.
It looks like I'm eating leaves.
Is this all water?
Let's see.
Oh, it is!
There's plenty of water on this map.
Not this one.
I like the music in this one.
Speaking of Tam Minto art, don't forget to use boomer for 10% off your gamersubs order.
Let's give Minto her own wife a cup.
Thank you!
So we have bloons, vtubers, super chats.
Speaking of the gamersubs, I do have to still...
I was thinking maybe instead of using a Google form...
My friend actually linked me to a website.
That might be better because I feel like a Google form...
I was thinking...
If some people retweet the form, you know?
And then it goes outside of my sphere and then people are just like, Free $100 coupon!
I'll take it!
Yeah, for the giveaway.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was just like, I want to give it to one of you guys.
I don't want to give it to some rando.
So...
I'm going to try the website.
It's one of those things where it's just like, Follow Femint Phantom on Twitter and subscribe to her channel.
One of those.
But I'm not going to make it so egregious where it's like, Tell your grandma!
Share on Facebook!
You know?
Gleam?
What's gleam?
No...
The one my friend sent me was...
Something else...
Tell grandma.
Retweet all of Minto's tweets for one entry.
Yeah, send to five friends.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want to do all of that.
I told my rabbit about you.
Thank you!
Alright.
We're going to put sawdust.
Do you think I can put sawdust?
Where do I go?
Where do the balloons go?
I guess we'll find out.
The music in this one is so fun!
Rabbits know a lot of critters too.
I showed my dog your snake eater short.
He loved it.
I'm honored!
Let's see.
Let's also do...
Let's put him here.
He's our backup defense.
How did your panel go, Mint?
That was fun!
It was so much fun!
It goes from the dotted lines and down your shoulder.
Wait.
So like...
Well, we'll see.
Here we go.
Wow!
I should have put that boat there.
What's wrong with me?
Let's put him here.
Long range!
Around my huge head?
It's for holding all my secrets!
Oh yeah!
Mermonkey!
I have seen Mermonkey.
I'm excited because Mermonkey looks like...
It looks like Mermonkey can go on land and on sea!
That's huge!
That's...
That's big news!
Alright then.
Keep your secrets.
Okay.
We're gonna...
Oops.
My bad.
I don't know why I pressed that on accident.
We're gonna work with these guys.
I wanna go with the middle, the middle, the middle.
Barb darts!
Once we get this, we can pierce the...
I think the next one can pierce the lead.
Yeah, yeah.
The lead and the steely ones.
Right?
I can really put Ice Monkey in your heart.
I wish there was a good place for Ice Monkey on this map.
Maybe...
Maybe my eyes...
Oh, that's not Ice Monkey.
Oh, I can't afford Ice Monkey.
There we go.
You could be kissing him.
The eyes are water.
Brick, you made this one, didn't you?
Kissing Ice Monkey.
Thank you for being so easy to show how awesome VTubers are.
I just showed my normie friends your rendition of Break Stuff and they...
They love it.
Really?
Oh my god!
What just happened?
Oh, I didn't mean to click that!
I meant to...
Oh my gosh, I meant to click this guy.
People love your Break Stuff.
I get so embarrassed.
I seriously...
I can't even, like, watch...
I can't listen to myself back about it.
Before watching Mint, I was a believer in laws like Murphy's Law where anything that can go wrong will go wrong.
Since I discovered Mint, my life has changed for the better.
Now I only believe in Cole's Law, which is shredded cabbage and creepy chips.
That
was actually so good!
It caught me...
It caught me so off-guard!
Oh my...
That one was so funny!
That one was so good, Kinky!
Cole's Law!
Oh wow!
I really like that one.
Let's do ballistic missiles.
Nice!
Now I get...
Yeah, Cole's Law!
It's cre...
It's shredded cabbage and creamy dressing!
But it's Cole's...
Law!
Damn it, I just got it.
Oh!
Glitch Face, your friend told me that you wanted to be at the con.
But you couldn't make it.
Thanks for explaining.
You're welcome!
You know what?
I also don't really like Cole's Law that much.
I'll be honest.
I'm not a hater.
But I don't like Cole's Law that much.
It's okay, you know?
Where do you think I can put...
Hmm...
Let's put Druid Monkey...
Let's put him over here.
So, wait...
Where do they go again?
Oh shoot, I think I'm too good at the game.
I can't tell what the path is.
It's this way, right?
It goes up and around down my shoulder.
I think.
Some recipes are better than others.
I was introduced to using Greek Yogurt for making Cole's Law.
Well, I think it's also...
I don't like raw cabbage at all.
I hate raw cabbage.
I love...
I will eat cooked cabbage for days.
But raw cabbage...
I really dislike.
I've eaten Cole's Law.
It's had 5 pounds of sugar and it's gross.
Ewww.
Sauerkraut?
I don't think I've ever had it.
She hates raw cabbage.
I do!
Just don't use raw cabbage then.
But isn't that like the point of Cole's Law?
Mint's Law.
She hates all her cabbage viewers.
Raise your hand if you're a cabbage viewer.
I'll personally apologize.
Maybe I can put him here.
Put him here, pal.
Oh, here maybe.
And then...
Put him here.
I can have...
Will the farms fit?
Oh, I don't think so.
Hold on, let's see how it works.
If I can fit...
Like...
Guys?
I thought I broke the game.
Good morning, Minto.
Doing great today?
You too, Magister!
The cabbage warriors.
I saw not a single hand.
I think you guys are lying.
I'm just kidding.
What is this part that makes it so I can't build on it?
I wonder.
Do I want to keep him here or not?
Oh!
We also need a plain monkey.
A plain...
monkey.
I'm gonna put plain monkey...
here.
Rapid fire.
Okay, here we go.
Well, we got plain monkey.
But when are we getting plantain monkey?
We're all cabbages.
You're the cabbage man from Avatar The Last Airbender.
My cabbages!
I'm gonna sell him.
Bye!
This map looks like the Vtuber Minto Minto.
I don't see the resemblance.
Whatever happened to the cabbage guy?
Was he okay?
Who?
Don't who me!
Nice!
Oh yeah!
Here we go, baby!
I think we're good for a minute.
Actually...
Hold on.
I wanna do this.
Do you think it'll reach?
Okay, you know what?
Hmm...
I don't think it'll reach...
Oh no!
I wanted to get...
both of them, but I don't think it'll reach.
Bigger.
Nooooo!
Hmm...
He made a company called Cabbage Corp.
They build automobiles.
We have enough for an ice monkey.
Yeah, we do.
I'll decide what I want.
I'll decide what I want to do after a few more.
I love never miss planes.
Look at that.
So awesome.
Ghost monkey win.
Yeah!
I mean we have necromancer monkey, but it's not the same.
Second village to make the first village longer.
Wait, can I do that?
How do you do that?
How would it...
This one?
Bunky city?
Increases influence...
This one, right?
Just overlap the zones.
Okay.
We'll do...
We'll do here.
What?
I keep accidentally pressing and I'm breaking the game.
Um...
Guys?
Oh!
Yippee!
It worked!
I didn't know that.
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
Okay.
We're not quite moab ready.
Good to know.
Secret monkey tech.
We'll make everybody faster at least.
Yeah, that was pretty bad.
That wasn't great.
Hmm...
Monkey farm.
I do need a monkey farm.
I need monkey everything.
Trying to save up money.
Monkey money.
Corvus is kind of a ghost monkey, but the cool part is that he commands a wisp.
Who's Corvus?
You're just making people up.
Micromanagement heavy though.
Oh, I forgot I also have this.
Use it for the next...
Let's see.
Let's do the moab glue.
So if we get another moab.
It should be real slow.
4-4-4-4!
We were at 4-4-4-4 money!
Spooky!
Where's ice monkey?
He's on vacation.
Glue gunner?
Glue gunner's pretty good.
I think glue gunner's a little underrated.
As you can see, it makes it really...
They really slow down a lot.
Where should I put him?
I could put him like...
See, I'm just like...
I want him close to some...
To some monkey...
Wait, it goes along the dotted line, right?
If I put him here...
He should still reach some...
Some farms then.
I think.
Hmm...
Also very good with sawdust.
Yeah!
Just above sawdust.
But it won't reach up here, right?
It goes through my hair.
This hair.
Not this hair.
If there's here...
This should be good.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Hmm...
Good job, everybody.
I wanna make money!
I actually use ice monkey more than glue gunner.
Ice monkey...
Will never work a day in his life.
Except he has all this experience.
And has popped like five balloons.
Works suck but coming home to Minto stream good.
Yay!
Otsu!
Otsu, Otsu, Otsu.
Freeloader.
Kinda.
I didn't say it though.
You did.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Come on, Saura.
Handle it.
Nice, everybody.
Nice.
Do I wanna up...
You know what?
I will upgrade this one.
Upgrade that one and then we make more money.
Don't let ice monkey's hands get dirty.
Everybody hates dirty ice.
That's the worst.
It gets so disgusting.
I was about to...
Unironically, I was about to start speaking like that one guy in Star Wars.
That's just like, I hate sand.
It's coarse.
I was gonna be like, I hate dirty ice.
It's gross.
It's dirty.
It's coarse.
I was about to unironically sound like that guy.
Anakin, yeah.
Nice.
Alright, let's get... You know what?
You go here.
Actually...
Here.
Then we can start...
I wonder if it'll reach.
I think so.
If I put one here...
No!
Doesn't fit.
Turn boiled pasta water into ice cubes to serve to guests that you don't like.
Ew.
Money, money, money.
Wait, I think it's...
It generates...
Oh...
I thought his range increased.
I do that with rubbing alcohol.
That doesn't sound legal.
I'll be honest.
Why did I do that?
I did not mean to do that.
That doesn't sound like...
Hahaha.
Doesn't sound very good.
Doesn't sound very legal.
I'll be honest.
But I've always...
I know...
I've always wanted to try like doing the ice...
The chocolate milk ice cubes and stuff like that.
That sounds good.
I do it with cyanide.
I also think that's not legal.
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh, we're almost there.
Oh, a coffee!
Coffee ice cubes!
Yes!
Oh my god, in just one shot.
I'll also give you a dancing monkey.
Don't worry, Brick, I'll give you a dancing monkey too.
Cold brew ice cubes would totally work.
Yeah!
Why use frozen coffee or chocolate milk when you could use ice cream?
Just ice...
But...
Ice cream, it doesn't...
The ice cream doesn't become like a...
It
doesn't become like a Q-Lube.
It's a different drink.
Oh no, the reinforced ones.
Wait, what did I... It's this guy, right?
He's our reinforcement.
Yeah, yeah, he shatters them shells.
We're gonna put you...
We're gonna put you right...
We're gonna stick you right...
You're gonna go right in...
We're gonna have you right...
We're gonna stick you right...
We're gonna...
You're gonna go right...
You're gonna stick her right in there.
Right there.
Hahaha.
There we go.
Oh my god!
Hi!
I was scared for a second.
Are you sure you didn't take that pill?
With the Benadryl?
No, I'm okay.
I'm okay!
Yeah.
Yeah!
I feel like I should have gotten more money from that.
Nice.
I'm just gonna keep going.
I'm just gonna keep on going.
Wait, how much...
How much do you have?
22!
Oh, we're not gonna get into the blue incineration.
That's kinda sad.
The big one.
Increases Bernie stuff damage.
Whoa!
Seems like a good couple.
Power couple.
No farms?
Nah, this is...
I'm...
I don't wanna be in...
This is the run where I...
I don't sell myself.
You know?
We're just doing it au naturel.
It's a big farm.
Poor mode.
Yeah.
Get it?
I'm trying to save up so we can get...
Maybe Spectre.
We're almost there.
We'll get there.
Oh, but maybe I want Spirit of the Forest.
I'll decide.
But Spectre is sooner than this one.
Monkey Paragon's win.
That's the...
That's like the triple...
The triplets, right?
I think we'll do Spectre.
Monkey Paragon.
Yeah, I gotta...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I think I need to finish...
Metal Gear Solid 2.
And Eternal Darkness.
Oh my gosh.
Before I leave for Japan!
Oh no!
And then I'll play 3 once I get home.
Is this a Monkey XP grinding stream?
It's a Monkey stream!
That was so fast.
Next we'll go for this guy.
Metal Gear Endurance stream, let's go!
Hell yeah.
I wouldn't say we're close to the end of MGS2.
I think we're like...
Halfway there.
But if I'm like strong next time...
I might be able to get it through it.
One or two more.
For sure.
Righty!
Thanks for three mobs.
The end does have a lot of cutting, you're right.
But...
Nice.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Look at him go!
What's the other plane?
The other one that's pretty good.
Oh, Skyshredder.
Oh wait, I have all of them unlocked.
See, I need more.
I need more XP.
I need a million XP and I only have 14,000.
Skip the cutscenes!
Never!
It's a lot grinding for paragons.
Yeah...
And I don't use anything like the...
Like the special stuff that they...
The monkey knowledges...
And things like that.
I'm unknowledged.
We're close to...
You were at 22?
You're still at 22.
Okay, that's fine.
Let's get to the 35,000.
Or 29,000.
I don't know.
Whichever you get.
Nice.
Even though your IQ is so high...
That's why it's so high.
I don't need to rely on cheats.
I don't need to rely on...
You know...
These simple...
These simple methods.
Mint is the one who finally got me into...
BTD 6.
What do you mean, finally?
How long have you been...
Waiting to play this game?
This one will also generate...
More money and more lives.
I love Spirit of the Forest.
Might be my favorite...
My favorite thing.
Nice!
Now we can see the pathway!
That's the real reason I got it.
A little more.
Nice.
Yep.
Now we know the real...
Pathway.
Basically wanted to wait for a sale.
I think it was on sale during the steam...
The steam sale, wasn't it?
Maybe I should do...
The banana farms over here.
And have it absorb them.
Like so.
Right?
Hmm...
Double mint?
I look like I'm wearing a thorn crown...
Now.
When did the DDT's come?
In 90, right?
I'm scared.
I'm scared for those!
90?
Yeah, okay.
Might be good...
To have this guy kind of facing down.
We can start working on our mega laser.
Hmm...
Which way do we want the laser?
Like if I go here...
It'll be like...
Hmm...
Also ships...
This is all...
This is all water, baby!
Wait...
Oh, I think because of my sleeve.
Hmm...
We can own this map?
Yeah!
You can go play this map yourself.
Just search Minto.
Cute maid!
Thank you!
Let's go sweat.
Probably, actually.
Sweaty, sweaty, sweaty.
Here, we'll get this guy.
We'll put him like right here.
And we'll do...
We'll do...
We'll do the pirate lord.
Yeah!
And the double shot.
Oh, I heard a DDT!
Oh!
We're so good!
We are so good!
We're gonna make it all the way, everybody.
I believe.
We're gonna make it all the way!
A break shot.
Don't jinx it.
What if I just casually get to 200?
Like, on just a one-off stream?
Where I'm just playing...
...
Yeah, I'm just playing Bloons just to, you know, hang out and play a game.
I'm just playing Bloons.
What about you?
We need 29,000.
You too.
The super glue.
You know what?
Let's do the super glue.
Autopilot gaming.
It does make me really relaxed though when I play this game.
And what I like is I can just kind of take a break in between like rounds.
I can be like, I gotta go do something.
And I'll leave and like just do it.
It's kind of awesome.
I stood around on the previous Minto map and died at 199.
No way.
What happened?
Basically cookie clicker.
There's a little more thought.
Oh, I haven't checked on my cookies in a while.
The BAD might be trouble.
Yeah, I think so too.
It's okay.
We're gonna upgrade.
We still have a few upgrades to do.
Like these two can still upgrade.
And this one can still upgrade.
So we're focusing on upgrading.
Which one do I want to do first?
We'll get this guy.
What does it do?
What does it do anyway?
Oh yeah, whenever MOA spawns, it like does a big ol' Yeah,
we're upgrading.
Don't worry, we're upgrading.
Don't be a...
Uh-oh.
What?
What went past?
Huh?
I didn't even see anything!
DDTs!
I didn't even see them!
I didn't even see them at all!
Steelycraze keeps giving you a little... I think Steelycraze is flirting with you.
Casually gets around 200.
Okay, okay.
I see you.
I will also give you one dancing RGB monkey.
Offstream though, offstream.
But I'll give you a monkey.
Who is Steelycraze?
I think... did they give this one too?
Who gave it to you?
Who gave this?
Need some paragons to reach level 200?
No!
I believe!
I believe we can go without it!
I... I know... Oh wait.
I know we can.
But guys, it's time.
It's time for the moment you've been waiting for!
One!
Two!
Ready?
Ice monkey...
The
music?
Wait, can monkey...
I have a question.
Can monkey destroy... Ice monkey destroy bloons or...
Does ice monkey only just freeze the bloons?
Yes?
The bottom path?
But what if I never make any money?
There's damage?
Okay.
All of them can pop?
Okay, okay.
So I'm just gonna put them out.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Ice Monkey.
This music is crazy.
Wait.
I don't think Ice Monkey can...
I don't think Ice Monkey can reach.
Wait, where did the...
I don't think Ice Monkey has...
Two... Wait!
Wait, it said they start over here!
Oh, they start here and then leave here.
I managed to make it past round 200 without Paragon.
So I believe he can do it.
Also, I did it on company time.
Let's go.
Go Ice Monkey!
Oh, he's slow.
Oh, Ice Monkey.
Oh, they circle multiple times.
Oh, Ice Monkey!
Ice Monkey, please!
I can't pop Camel.
I think.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
I guess we'll do Ice Monkey plus Village.
Enhanced Freezing.
Tax Faster.
That's what we need.
Okay, buddy.
Enhanced.
Enhanced Ice Monkey.
Man, we should go.
Oh, Top Path.
Okay, well we're going to have so many Ice Monkeys, you guys.
Like...
We're going to be able to do every single path.
It's got a nice crunch.
Ice Monkey!
Don't just juggle.
You're losing lives.
This one.
Can freeze and pop.
Pop!
Super cold aura that slows bloons and freezes water nearby.
Wait, this might be good, right?
I'm gonna go for the bottom path though.
For now.
Guys, we might run out of lives before we...
Maybe I should have put Ice Monkey in a different spot.
But if we have to redo it, that's okay too.
Because I just didn't know where the path was.
Good job, Ice Monkey!
0-2-5 is my way to go.
Oh my gosh.
Why are Ice Monkeys so expensive?
Oh, come on!
Come on!
It's 425 and we're at 423!
This is so messed up.
Go Ice Monkey!
Okay, I'm gonna slow it down.
So we can make another Ice Monkey.
Why can't I only put in some places and not others?
Oh my god.
Ice Monkey.
Do something!
Nice.
Wow, six shades.
You guys, the music is so fitting for this, honestly.
Yeah.
Get the Ice Mon...
Wow, nice, nice.
Oh my gosh.
We're just bleeding.
You guys, we're bleeding lives.
Oh no, wait.
That was the wrong monkey.
Too many Ice Monkeys.
I can't keep up with Ice Monkey.
Okay.
It's okay though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
Go, go!
We only lost one life that time.
Not enough Ice Monkey.
Shoot smaller Ice Bombs.
Increases Pierce.
Okay.
Let's go for that.
But also, how do we want to go with this guy?
Let's do that.
Let's unlock this.
Okay.
Maybe I should have had Ice Monkey gain more XP.
You guys, let's try and get to round 40.
Let's try and get through the map, okay?
That's what...
That's what our goal will be.
Okay.
That's what the goal will be.
Just get through the map.
Get through...
Get through the map.
Oh, my God.
I was so poor.
I need more money.
Okay, nice.
Look, they're working together.
They're really working together.
Ice.
Yeah!
Clap, Monkey, clap!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
Clap, clap, clap.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, that's fine.
Keep going.
Clap.
Clap, Monkey!
Clap!
Deep freeze.
It's getting breezy in here.
It's getting breezy.
Nice.
I like the sound they make.
It's really crunchy.
No juggling?
They juggle on their own time.
They juggle when they have time.
I like that.
I wish, though, I put Monkey over here, Monkey here, you know?
I wish I could also put Monkey out here.
We got to get them all.
Maybe I just, like, spam Monkey in here.
Let's put Monkey over here.
First Monkey defense.
Ain't making it.
What are you talking about?
I'm not making it.
We're going to make it.
Go.
See?
He's getting some.
Oh.
The yellow ones, we don't care about those.
They can leave.
They're not invited.
Is this the dark blue water?
I'm actually not sure.
I think this is definitely water.
I can't tell until we make more money.
This guy can go with...
Attack's faster.
We'll go with this one.
You're doing it.
Kind of.
Oh my God.
We've lost so many lives.
Guys.
I don't know if we're going to make it.
Yeah, this is all water.
This is all water.
Water.
Love the chill stream.
Thanks!
It's so ice over.
Come on Ice Monkey!
Come on!
Clap!
Ice Monkey!
Make more
money!
Nice!
He's soloing!
Get popped!
Clap!
We need to increase our monkey.
Get popped!
Yes!
Pop!
Oh gosh...
Hey!
Someone is not doing their job!
It looks like Ice Monkey has really stupid googly eyes.
I'm Ice Monkey!
Clap!
Pop the monkey!
I've popped the balloon!
Oh, it's so over.
The disrespect of that one red balloon.
Hold on, let's restart.
Let's restart.
We have... We are... 22 is the new 40.
We are... We are... We are stronger now.
I tried doing this with just Ice Monkey and couldn't do it so I gave up because one type of balloon.
That's why I failed.
It's okay.
It's only three.
Next.
There we go.
Nice.
Yep.
Yes.
Yes...
Oh...
He was frozen and then...
And then he wasn't.
Don't judel at a time like this.
It's embarrassing.
Enhanced freeze.
Thanks for the laughs.
Thanks for laughing AbbeyKrew.
Kyaa... kyaa, kyaa... kyaa... kyaa...
Kyaa... kyaa... kyaa... kyaa... kyaa... kyaa... kyaa...
All in?
Okay, I think I'm gonna go all in on two monkeys.
I think having two is good.
I think... anymore... I won't have enough money.
You know what I mean?
I think I need to go in on two monkeys.
For now.
Until we can hold our own.
You know?
You're in for a bad time once the white bloons show up.
But this one can...
One of them...
One of them will work?
Right!
One of these will be able to take care of it!
Look, we're already doing so much better than before!
Freeze!
Clap!
No!
Red bloon!
Get him!
Yeah!
I uh... went against my...
We're gonna give this guy...
I don't know.
We're just gonna... he's our backup.
He's our backup monkey.
We're saving up for... this one.
Rapidly shoot smaller ice bombs.
We're saving up.
Ship!
Ship!bridge!
Tail seep.
It's gonna die.
Now he's looking down.
Yeah.
In disgust to... Disgust to... how disappointed he is.
Oh my god.
No!!!
Come on!!
That can do it!
Finished using Next to that- like here?
In the crease.
Save.
Hold on, that's a good idea.
I'm going to sell him.
Put him here.
You're so right.
Top of the eye would be better.
Is it?
Every game we learn a new... Why aren't you doing anything?
Pop him!
I'm saving up.
I'm saving up for the cryo...
Okay.
So he's looking up.
Things are looking up from here.
This guy can't even reach larger... There we go.
Goodness gracious.
What's this one?
Oh, let's do this.
I said I was saving up.
4, 4, 4!
Oh my god.
It's so fast.
You're so slow.
Why are you so...
You can't even hit that guy.
Solid snake eyes.
Fuck you.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
You're too slow.
Oh, he's going to get this guy though.
We're still at 169.
8.
Okay.
Maybe I should just restart then.
I want to see what this does.
Cryo cannon.
If we can even get there.
Oh.
Single red, blue.
Okay.
Go, go, go.
It's always that one blue and I know, right?
Come on.
Oh, they're regenerating.
Everything is bad.
Everything sucks.
Here it is.
There it goes.
148!
Were they close to it?
So I just want to see what it does.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Everybody.
We're so close.
This round.
We got this.
Spieve, everybody.
Oh, dang it.
Okay.
Next.
Oh.
There we go.
Let's try it out.
Wait.
Are these the guys that...
Oh, he can't even get all the yellow ones though.
Okay.
Let's go.
You're so slow.
He's kind of awesome...
Oh, here we go.
Guys.
I think this challenge is impossible!
I think this challenge...
It's on easy difficulty!
I think this challenge is impossible!
What are the white ones?
Are they...
Are you feeling 22?
What do the white balloons count as?
I don't even think I've ever considered what they are.
The white ones cannot be frozen.
Free as a mule!
Oh, immune to ice.
That's why I never knew.
This ice monkey map is probably made by an ice monkey hater.
Oh my god!
Guys, I don't even know if we would be able to afford...
I don't think we could afford it.
Like...
I don't think we could afford an ice monkey getting as good as it did before.
And then also...
You always use...
Oh, oh, oh, ice monkey!
Look, look, like...
Let's see...
Oh, gosh!
Cha, cha, cha, cha, cha, cha, cha!
Cha!
A village is 1,020.
And then in the middle, right?
6,000!
There's no way.
There's no way we'd get there in time with also upgrading a monkey.
Oh no, is this challenge impossible?
No!
Is this challenge impossible?
Get a dart, monkey.
That's not the point!
The challenge is ice monkey only!
Oh, no!
Snowstorm.
Freeze all regular bloons on screen.
Briefly freezes.
Why zebra camo and slows mo...
Wow.
Let's try putting the ice monkey at the top.
Hmm...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Oh, I need the larger...
The larger radius is 150.
Will I have enough?
Like here?
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
Go!
Not a single life lost, baby!
Oh, my God.
We're making it out of the ice age with this one.
Don't get your hopes up.
Huh!
We're on round three and we still have 200 lives, everybody.
Huge!
Then we just get the deep freeze.
No!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
I like the crunchy sounds.
Me too!
Sounds really good.
I'm going to start using ice monkey all the time.
Yeah!
She's a master of only one element.
Three months for ice monkey!
I did it!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh!
That's the good stuff!
That's the...
It sounds like it's going to be...
It's going through every crevice of my brain wrinkles.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
I wish I could make the clapping a little less loud, but...
Oh, yeah.
Go through my brain.
Crackle!
Yeah.
Ice monkey ASMR.
Next model ice monkey cosplay.
What are you talking about?
Oh, my God.
You have brain wrinkles?
Oh, sorry.
I know that's a foreign concept to you.
Yeah.
Most brains...
Hold on.
I'll say this really slowly for you, Kason.
Brains that think brain think thinking wrinkles.
No wrinkle, no think.
You?
No wrinkle.
You monkey brain.
You think like monkey.
But mint?
Really wrinkly.
No sunscreen ever.
No skin care.
Only wrinkle.
Hag monkey.
No think.
I mean only...
Wait.
Only wrinkles.
Hag monkey.
Only...
Oh, gosh.
We lost.
We lost one, boys.
We lost one.
But...
I don't think we're going to make enough money in time, though.
Have you used any of your knowledge points?
You can make ideas out of them.
But still, I think that you can get an ice monkey stronger if you wanted to, or other monkeys.
I haven't used a single monkey point.
Ever.
What is this map?
It's ice monkey map, baby.
We're not going to make enough money.
I don't have money for a monkey, but I'll do my best to make enough for a mon... key.
Your brain is smooth.
No, you are brain is smooth.
We've only lost a little bit of lives, but that's okay.
I think you need another ice monkey.
We won't have any money.
It would cost so much to get zero... zero... wait.
It would cost much less to get zero four ice than to get zero three... oh wait.
What's zero four... wait.
I can't even get the four though!
I don't have enough EXP!
I don't have enough.
Bold words come from the ghost who said the difference between 181 and 187 is five at the beginning of the stream.
You're making fun of me!
You're making fun of my dyscalculia!
I have a learning disability!
You're gonna make some fun of someone with a learning disability?
Mint color for mint, okay?
Yeah,
we're gonna have to train ice monkey to redo... I think we're gonna have to do a...
We're gonna have to...
Do like a revenge for this.
We're gonna have to revenge.
Yellow is just flying by.
Don't look at them.
Yellow is a horrible color.
Two thousand.
It's impossible.
It's really impossible.
So then what...
What is black bloons?
What are they immune to?
Green is not a creative color.
What are you talking about?
There's like only three green VTubers.
Okay.
Oh, explosions.
Oh my gosh.
Here it is.
My demise.
Here we go.
Bye.
Yo, super chat.
Man.
Oh well.
Monkey money!
I wanna get to the... where's the...
I have 33 monkey points.
Yo, you can't see cause chat's blocking it.
I have 33 of them.
Wait.
Oh well, I haven't used any of them.
I was like enable monkey knowledge, but I don't use it.
Try Corvus.
Where's that guy?
Which one is him?
Him?
Oh yeah!
I don't have enough money.
I don't have enough.
Look at...
Is this you?
Is that you?
You're like...
Monkey!
Is that you?
Literally me.
He's got Venom's hand.
He stole your color.
What?
The little wisp guy?
I mean, basically all ghosts are either a shade of green or blue.
It's like ghost lore.
Everybody...
Every ghost has to be green or blue.
That's just the way.
Wait, so is he a ghost?
A spirit walker.
Corvus works well on the front line.
Weakening nearby bloons to harvest mana and challenge powerful energies through his spirit companion.
Or white.
Oh yeah, white's fine too.
White's also good.
Oh, purple?
Purple's also fine.
Because...
Gengar, you know.
Luigi's Mansion is fiction.
Those are all paid actors.
Luigi's Mansion doesn't count.
Luigi is a fraud.
He's a big old phony.
He's just like, oh, I'm a ghost hunter.
No, he's not.
Those guys are literally there to be sucked...
up...
into a vacuum.
Why do you hate Luigi?
Because...
I don't hate Luigi.
I just hate that he's a phony.
Green envy.
What about Ghostbusters?
Aren't those guys green?
Main screen!
Poor Luigi!
Mint a Wario fan?
I'm a WaLuigi fan.
Maybe that's why I'm a Luigi hater?
I'm like WaLuigi.
I like Waluigi.
But can I be the wah-Luigi?
He's the correct answer!
Oh, that's worse?
How is that worse?
Luigi is just like a little weenie.
He's just like, oh brother.
Mama mia.
And Mario is fine.
Actually, I hate Mario.
I hate Mario.
I hate that guy.
Mario can...
Mario can get stuck in a pipe.
Okay, Bowser.
Yeah, Bowser!
My name is Mario?
Is it actually?
King Boo confirmed.
Yeah!
I love King Boo!
I love Boo!
What is your favorite monkey hero?
And why is it Sada in this skin?
I'm gonna need some coffee.
Hold on, I'm gonna have a snack.
No, this is the chocolate one!
I want a peanut butter!
No!
Wait guys, I gotta go get a peanut butter.
Peanut butter bar.
Give me a second.
I have a chocolate bar, but I want a peanut butter bar.
Give me one second.
Give me one second!
I'm gonna run and grab it.
It's in my kitchen.
I'll be back in one second.
Give me one second.
Pat firsty.
One second.
One second!
I also got a cookie sandow.
Yeah!
Tokyo banana.
Cookie sandow.
It says cookie sand.
I'm gonna try this.
I don't think I've had this yet.
Yummy.
Whoa!
It's just got a big ol' slice of...
Smells like banana.
And cookie.
Exactly as advertised!
Men, eat peanut butter!
You can't make me!
But I do have a peanut butter bar.
Peanut butter is made for monkeys.
Is it a nature valley sweet and salty chewy nut bar?
No, it's a...
It's a...
Gamer shop suss bar.
What are you doing over there Scooby Snack?
Just call the boober.
Why do you sound so upset?
Because you guys will judge me!
Was it free?
Yeah.
They're literally feeding this girl.
They're feeding me!
It's a sustainable, nutritious food bar!
And it's peanut butter flavored.
And it was free!
Peanut butter!
And it's peanut butter and free!
How can I say no?
Free food tastes better.
Exactly!
Shut up, Murphy.
Why does me being goofy have to do with starving?
Yeah, free food!
My only thing about this bar...
Is it tastes like the peanut butter...
The peanut butter that's like Japanese peanut butter.
Which is just, for some reason, very sweet.
Let's um...
I don't really like sweet peanut butter.
Isn't Japanese mayo sweet as well?
It can be, yeah.
They like... like the bread is sweet.
The peanut butter is sweet.
I don't want so much sweet all the time.
Which is so funny because people are like, Oh, Japanese food is not sweet.
It's so like...
You know, it's so bland.
And I'm like, no, it's sweet!
How did I get to the...
Was it this?
Oh, here we go.
Let's look up the most liked.
Some of these are like serious...
This one is...
This one is so funny.
Sada's best map.
It's so funny.
But some of these are like real art.
Look at jungly wongly.
What the hell?
Nothing gets past my axe, boy.
My wish order is shipping route.
Hahaha.
Jungly wongly.
Inception.
Whoa!
Vaporeon's garden.
Kronko would like that one.
Among Us Among Us!
Mega Man's map.
Oh wait, that's not actual Mega Man.
Oh, there's Maxwell.
I like this one already.
Some of these are so awesome.
Blondes.
Blondes if it was good.
First monkey shooter.
Plants vs.
Blondes!
Shut up.
Oh my god!
No way!
Wait, what?
How does this work?
Huh?
I'm just gonna put it right here.
I don't know where they're gonna come from.
They're from all over!
Oh.
Oof.
Hahaha.
There's a monkey on your lawn.
Sunflower.
I'm done with this one.
Go home.
That one seems hard.
There's another one!
What the hell?
They're made by two different people!
Plants vs.
Zombies.
You think he'd be able to reach everyone?
He might be able to.
Four paths now.
Look, they come over.
This is so genius!
What?
What the hell?
This is just so...
It just is so...
So good!
So well made!
Let's try if I...
Oh wait.
Maybe like right here.
Let's see if it works.
Go!
Nice.
His reach.
I
think I realize what this stream has made me realize.
I think I need a break from Bloons.
I feel like I'm like...
Oh yeah, Bloons.
Yeah, I played it.
Okay.
I think I'm like...
I think I'm not...
I think I'm like kinda...
I'm Bloonsed out a little bit.
No such thing.
Yeah, I'm Bloonsed out.
Plants vs.
Zombies next stream.
Seeing this, I was just like more excited about the Plants vs.
Zombies than the Bloons.
But I'm really curious how this one gets with like the MOABs.
Where do they... what?
Do four MOABs come out and stuff?
I'm so curious how it'll work.
We'll keep playing.
We'll keep playing for now.
We'll keep trying it for now.
Four MOABs.
Oh my...
But you get like a ton of money from this though, right?
Like, there's so many here.
Let's... for this guy, let's go with the Pirate.
Oh.
Well, I spent all my money.
Nevermind.
This guy...
This guy will go for the top one.
I just got here and you're already tired of it.
I'm sorry!
Here is where I'm gonna put an airplane.
When I can afford it.
Same amount of Bloons, just different tracks.
Seriously?
Okay.
It is the same amount though?
It looks like so much more.
Is this actually how many Bloons I've been...
I've been shooting this whole time?
That's crazy.
These little monkeys are so powerful.
Look at him go.
Don't forget the sunflower.
Yeah, the sunflower will bring us more money.
Cool.
Each lane houses a quarter of the Bloons in each round.
So it would be...
Only one MOAB on the first lane.
Oh, place in the editor.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, because these new custom maps are pretty recent.
So I don't know so much about them yet.
Let's do...
Let's do double shot.
We'll just keep upgrading this guy.
Nice.
I wanna...
I wanna see how it looks.
Look at all these zombies.
It would be fun if I had like a...
You know how like they make skins for the Bloons?
It would be fun if I like...
Had one that made it like kind of...
Dead looking.
No, that is not Mega Man.
Dear Mint, I hope this message finds you well.
By the time this Donut Alert appeared, I found the Tuturu Gacha.
I'm asleep.
Good night!
Oh, I thought I lost a life.
But I didn't.
I think it...
Oh, yes I did.
I think I lost a some...
...
Easy.
Easy, easy, easy.
Yes.
Plants vs.
Zombies map.
I know, right?
You guys, the Tuturu is a lie.
I don't know where that lie came from.
Like, I don't know where that rumor started.
It's so weird.
But...
You know.
It's so weird.
How that started and...
Oh my god, we're losing lives.
For me?
Oh, I can't put the plane here.
What can I put here?
Little dart monkey.
For me?
How dare you?
How dare you say that?
I missed the Tuturu lie.
It couldn't have been you.
Yeah, it wasn't me.
It was not me.
I can tell you that with full confidence.
Oh my gosh, I can even put monkeys out here?
What?
That's crazy.
Wait.
The monkeys can go anywhere.
Look, he's outside of bounds.
Wait.
Warrior monkey.
Rolling for mint noise.
Nice monkey.
Why aren't you doing anything?
Handle it.
Uh oh.
I instinctually said...
Hello chat.
He's watching.
Yeah, he is.
He's judging.
He's watching.
Let's see.
That's crazy.
I can't put one on top of the fence.
Which kind of sucks.
I could just have a monkey out here.
Yep.
Let's see.
Maybe ninja monkey would be good at the end.
That guy is fast.
Can I do more than one on here?
Well, I don't know.
Hey, ninja monkey.
You're supposed to be fast.
We're losing lives.
The ice monkey in mint.
He did nothing wrong.
He brought coleslaw to the barbecue.
Oh my god.
Ninja monkey.
What is wrong with you?
We're gonna die at this rate.
Whoa.
There's so many.
Potato salad is much better.
Exactly.
I'm hearing my name.
Are you a slaw?
Did you just dox yourself?
First name Cole, last name slaw.
Nice.
Is that bad?
I'm familiar with barbecue etiquette.
At a minto barbecue.
BBQ.
No slaw!
No coleslaw!
Oh, you're making me want chicken salad.
Try making a custom map with chat sometime.
The map editor is pretty goofy.
I have to... Here, let's see.
I'm just gonna... We'll get through these rounds.
We'll see if we make it to round 40.
And then, um...
I think, what?
I think it's 6,000 monkey bucks?
I will pay for more monkey bucks if I have to.
Kimchi coleslaw?
I'll be honest.
I don't think I've ever had kimchi before.
Because it's always spite.
It's always spicy.
He's doing it!
Oh my god, he's doing it!
Having a ninja monkey was so great!
Oh, come on, ninja monkey.
Why did you let that guy slip past you?
Yes.
I think we're gonna make it.
Oh, I have so much money.
Why am I not upgrading?
I have so much money.
Donating to Mint's legal defense for the Tuturu case.
Thank you.
Thank you, Xenophobe.
I appreciate it.
Nice.
He's faster.
He's stronger.
Nice.
He's faster.
He's stronger.
Wait, this one we're going with the top.
I'm surprised he got all of those.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Oh, we got this in the bag, everybody.
We got this in the bag!
Doesn't have to be spicy.
I had some soggy kimchi from a jar and it was okay.
Maybe worth trying again.
Maybe it's supposed to be soggy from a jar.
I don't know.
Being in a custom map doesn't give you any monkey money.
Because you could just make the longest map possible and Trivial clear any game mode for...
Oh, I guess that's fair.
Here we go.
Yippee!
We did it.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy.
Let's go see how much it is and how much I got.
Oh, wait.
I have almost 5,000 monkey bucks.
And it is 6,000.
Or it's 7 dollars.
If I buy more...
I would need 2,000 more.
I could just do the 5,000 one, I guess.
Not worth.
50 dollars for 50,000 mountain of monkey money.
That's insane.
You'll need a team of monkey Sherpas to reach the summit of this awesome mountain of monkey money.
Why does it have a description?
Why
does it have a description?
Go for the sale?
I'm not going to lie.
I was kind of looking at the sale.
Don't do it.
But...
But I want to make our own maps.
You guys, I want us to create a map together.
We can make a Metal Gear map.
Those don't exist.
I've looked them up already.
Monkey money funds.
No, Garlimauld, don't do it, please.
Don't give me any, please.
Not for monkey.
No, not for monkey.
It's only 12 dollars.
They're a cool dev team.
Yeah, they give us a lot of stuff.
I guess.
I don't know.
Shadow Moses map or Groznygrad map?
Granini gra... Granini gra... Granini...
Granini Gorge map.
Monkey...
No, I don't know.
How much did the base game cost?
I think it was 7 dollars.
I don't remember how much it was when I bought it.
Embrace your inner monkey.
Is it 12 dollar tax right now?
No, you guys.
Here's some money so you can make a weapon that surpasses monkey gear.
Usually... okay, this is my thought process.
This is my thought process with games.
When a game... well, this one isn't free to play.
But I usually have this kind of mentality with, like, gacha games.
Like, for example, like, I'm Blue Archive.
I'm Sensei.
So, if a game is free to play, you know?
Like, if it's a gacha game.
But I... and I enjoy it so much.
I'll, like, throw, like, 5 bucks a month at it, you know?
Because I'm like, you know, it's providing me entertainment and fun.
And so I'm just like...
I want it to continue.
So I get when people are like...
Oh, I don't spend any money on gacha games.
But I'm just like...
But I want it to keep going.
High roller.
I know, right?
I spend how much I feel the game is worth to me.
It's how they get you.
Yeah, but I, like, I do it in moderation.
Now, that's on you.
That's on you if you can... if you get caught in that spider web.
That's on you.
You are providing me entertainment and fun.
And I want you to continue.
Oh my god, Teacup!
Am I gonna see you again today?
You guys, I saw...
I saw...
I met people yesterday.
It was so fun.
Wailing is a skill issue.
So true.
But also, Blue Archive is, like, so generous.
I've already gotten the two unique girls from the free temples.
But I need Iroha.
Dress Hina next week?
Fight to prove that your will is weak.
Wait, let's see.
How much was Bloons on here?
Let's see.
Store page.
Bloons?
No, no, no.
Bloons is...
$14?
What?
I will not be buying the monkey money.
No way.
Okay, I spent $14 on your game and you're gonna make me pay for more monkey money?
Increase the price due to the updates.
I was gonna say, I did not spend that much on it.
Minakari, thanks for the 10 gifted.
That's crazy, though.
I mean, they do give you a good amount of cash.
Like, I haven't...
I haven't spent anything...
Or rather, I haven't bought any.
And I spent it on Sada and her skin.
So, you know.
They do give you a lot of monkey money.
But dang.
Dang.
Wait, what?
Hold on.
I'm so sorry about that.
Basically, I saw...
Okay, my phone, I think, did like a freaky AI, like, message thing to be like, This is what the phone call is about something something.
I was like, huh?
Because I was saying that my cat had an ultrasound today.
I was like, no.
That's not possible.
But I actually do have to get going because my cat is out of his medicine.
And I've been waiting a couple days for the vet to get back.
To me to refill it so I could go get it.
And...
Cat's freaky?
No.
He's a man.
I mean, he's got no balls.
But he's...
I've seen his pink thing, unfortunately.
Unfortunately.
But, yeah.
They close relatively soon.
So, I have to go and...
Sorry.
I was like, huh?
But I've been waiting for their phone call.
So, I...
Yeah.
Thanks for the stream, Mito.
It's okay.
I didn't intend on having a super duper long stream today.
Because I was like, wow, I'm going to be doing meet and greets.
Tomorrow, I won't have a stream either.
I'm really sorry.
Because I will be at the convention all day.
But Sunday, I will be continuing Metal Gear Solid 2.
Probably.
Maybe I'll start sooner.
Maybe I'll aim to endurance it.
Maybe.
Actually, I might do that.
Thanks to the panel today and for the stream.
Frankie!
I can't believe you.
I can't believe you wouldn't introduce who you were.
This guy.
This guy comes up and is just like, yeah, I'm probably the oldest wisp here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm just like, wait.
What's your name?
And he's just like, I'm Memboo number two.
And I...
I saved all the Memboo cards.
But they were in a different folder than I thought.
So, I couldn't find it at the moment.
So, I'm just like, wait.
I have to go digging and then I was like, yeah.
Where is he?
You?
Memboo number two?
I'll never forget that.
I'll never forget that now.
He made you work.
I know.
He lied.
It was me, Minto.
I'm the oldest.
Who's Memboo number one?
That's Paige.
Who's around here sometimes.
But it was something.
It was Memboo number one.
If you went to Off-Kite, you maybe met Paige.
I remember.
I try to remember you guys.
Even though I couldn't remember number two.
Anyway, thank you guys for Bloonsin' with me.
You know what?
We're gonna try harder with the...
With the Ice Monkey Challenge next time.
We will...
We will complete the Ice Monkey Challenge in some capacity.
We will have it done.
But I'm gonna take a break from Bloons for a while since I'm, you know...
Since I was like...
I don't know.
It's so weird because this is usually my comfy game but...
I'm kinda Bloonsed out.
Maybe that's why I'm Bloonsed out.
Because I've played it too much.
I bet there are some people cheering.
They're just like...
Yeah!
No more Bloons!
This is what happens when I have no Minecraft, you guys.
Weedie!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Too much of a good thing?
Maybe.
Terraria?
That might be fine.
Okay.
I'm gonna go get my cat's medicine.
That was...
I guess good timing-ish because I...
Yeah.
Uh...
War Tortoise!
Thanks for a buy!
Thank you, thank you.
Luigi Mansion.
Luigi...
Weegee Mansion.
This is what no Minecraft does to a MF.
Mint Phantom.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me!
And I will see you guys...
Sunday!
Metal Gear!
Probably alllll dayyyy!
All day.
Metal Gear.
All day Metal Gear!
All day.
Metal...!
Oh!
But also.
If you do want some Minto action tomorrow...
The panel that Ayami and I will be...
A part of.
At Anime Fest Dallas will be streamed on Twitch, so you can see the both of us there as well.
We have a little funny... Fun panel...
That Ayami-sensei actually thought of, so...
Also!
Oh my gosh, I asked her.
We've been trying to do this for a while, but we wanted to have an off-collab, and now since I'm going to be in Japan for a long time, we're going to do it!
We're going to have an off-collab.
So if you guys have any suggestions on what kind of off-collab you would like for us to do, feel free to suggest that with me and Ayami-sensei.
Marriage stream!
Oh my gosh, what if we could go to a shooting range?
ASMR?
In Japan?
Yeah, there are shooting ranges in Japan!
I don't know how we would film that though, or how we would stream that though.
Maybe I can take a video of it.
Maybe we can go together and I'll make a video.
Take a video.
Or something.
My first ever shooting range too.
We'll see.
Anyway, okay.
Thank you guys!
I'm going to try, since I'll be in Japan for a while too, I'm going to try and get lots of fun stuff filmed as well.
Filmed, and I'll of course keep streaming.
I have... actually.
Actually.
Because I will.
I actually got a better hotel this time.
But yeah, for real this time.
For real this time.
And hopefully I won't get sick.
Okie dokie!
Thank you guys.
I will see you guys later.
Have a good night!
If I see you at the convention, at Anime Fest in a couple hours with the...
With the...
A little meet and greet.
I'll see you then!
Otsumintou!
Itterashiaimase!
Bye bye!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
You can still hear me!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community